toutes les fédérations de l'éducation
nationale sont venus devant le rectorat
de l'académie de dijon bhb une unité
syndicale contre les suppressions de
postes prévues à la rentrée 2010 9 dans
les lycées et les collèges
sa suppression de postes en collèges
sont liées à la réforme du collège qui a
eu lieu il ya quelques années et qui
continue à faire des ravages 2650
suppressions de postes dans le second
degré auquel s'ajoutent 400 postes et
des personnels administratifs
[Musique]
on sait que la rentrée 2010 9 c'est
l'équivalent d'un rectorat d'académie
qui doit être rayé de la carte
les syndicats dénoncent la casse de la
fonction publique et une situation
incohérente au regard du nombre d'élèves
qui ne cesse de croître dans les lycées
quant à l'augmentation du nombre de
postes dans le premier degré déjà
amorcée l'an dernier elle ne suffit pas
même s'il ya eu et l'année prochaine ce
sera encore le cas des ouvertures de
postes dans le premier degré elles ne
sont pas à la hauteur des besoins
puisque monsieur blanc caire a décidé de
dédoubler les postes en cp et l'année
prochaine
en ce1 dans les écoles de rep pour
dédoubler dans de bonnes conditions il
aurait fallu non pas 1800 postes comme
ça avec le cas mais 4000 colère aussi
des enseignants des lycées
professionnels eux refuse la création
d'une seconde généraliste qui réduira
d'un an
la formation des élèves en bac pro on
part sur un bac professionnel préparer
en trois ans mais les élèves ne seront
formés à leur métier que sur deux années
de formation
donc on supprime encore une année de
formation ce qui ne pourra entraîner
automatiquement qu une déqualification
des élèves tous y compris les stagiaires
de l'école supérieure du professorat et
de l'éducation
inquiets pour leur avenir sont
déterminés à défendre la qualité de
l'enseignement du service public
[Applaudissements]